i think that there are a lot of  questions that we justifiably have and  we want answers because if the fbi can  do this to president donald trump they  can do it to you and the american people  know that that is such a silly talking  point what does it mean  if they can do it to trump they can do  it to you  is a president our vips are wealthy  socialites the elites whatever term you  want to use the bilderbergs no i'm not  doing the jones thing um  are should they be exempt  should they get special treatment and  also we know it can happen to all of us  it happens to all of us all the time  that's the whole point the point is it  doesn't happen to these people at the  top echelons of society